this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
I want to take a moment to talk about
super secondary structures and motifs
before we get into territory structure
okay so let's start off with a little
definition okay so when it comes to
super secondary structures and motifs
the two terms are sometimes used
interchangeably sometimes they're used
slightly differently so super secondary
structures are basically combinations of
secondary structures that one have a
particular characteristic shape and to
appear in a variety of proteins okay
like I said sometimes that that also
just that definition applies for motifs
as well okay I for the most part use the
terms interchangeably some people don't
and I'll get to kind of where people
talk about them as super secondary
structures and when they talk about them
as motifs okay so let me give you some
examples of secondary structures okay so
here we have a beta a hairpin to the far
left we've got two anti parallel beta
strands connected by this little loop
here this little beta turn okay so that
that is a combination of two secondary
structures two beta pleated sheets and
that specific situation there is a beta
hairpin okay we can also have two
parallel beta pleated sheets with an
alpha helix between them that's
specifically a beta alpha beta unit okay
that's a super secondary structure beta
meander so we here we got a series of
anti-parallel beta-pleated sheets
there's five that I've drawn
specifically and they're connected start
to finish from here here around and then
down here and then up and then down all
the way through to that fifth one okay
so that is a beta meander that's very
similar to the Greek key in that we have
these beta pleated sheets all anti
parallel but the connection is different
okay instead of just going up and up and
over and then down and up and then up
and over and down enough here we're
starting from the
alright go up and we don't go directly
to the one next to me we go to this one
here then we come back to go up and up
and through and then down and all the
way over to the left ok so that specific
combination and connectivity is a Greek
key that combination of beautifully the
cheese is called a Greek key and then we
have a helix-turn-helix which is pretty
much exactly what it sounds like
we've got alpha-helix a little turn and
then another alpha-helix so here we have
a protein called pin one and in it we
have a beta hair pin so if we zoom in
here we can follow this beta strand up
in this direction then around this
hairpin loop to the base of this beta
sheet which we can follow here to where
it ends here so this here is human
proliferating cell nuclear antigen and
as you can tell it's got a lot of
different beta pleated sheets and in it
it's got this sort of beta meander type
structure so if we take it out we can
see that it's not a complete beta
meander but it does have these
alternating beta pleated sheets for
instance this one starts right here and
we could follow it down like this and
then it's got this little loop at the
bottom here and then it goes back and
this other anti parallel beta sheet you
know we have another loop and I mean
come down this strand as well so that's
kind of how I beta me and it looks so
over here we have the protein banana
lectin and it's got a bunch of Greek
keys and so what I did was I highlighted
this specific chain and I removed its
atoms and bonds and just to sort of
reveal the beta pleated sheets and then
I cut off the portion that was just one
Greek key and that's how I got this over
here right over to the left so let's get
rid of that and take a closer look at
this Greek key so we zoom in on it first
we start off down here and with this
beta strand that sort of goes up and
then we have this long loop that leads
into this anti parallel beta strand and
we have this smaller loop here and then
another
antiparallel strands going upwards and
then we get another one of these small
loops and that leads into this other
anti parallel strand and that leads into
another small loop and then we have this
anti parallel strands upwards and
another large loop at the very end
leading and ending with that way to
shade there so that's a Greek key so
this is Khattab light at two Vater
protein and it's got a helix turn helix
in it it's actually right here so we can
see here we've got a helix a little turn
and then another helix and this can
actually be seen more obviously if we
get rid of all the different atoms and
bonds and we just take a look at it like
this right so we can take a look at this
and see the helix here and then we have
the turn and then we have the helix over
here on this end and this can go through
and fit into the protein right there
okay so these guys tend to show up in
proteins in this way and for that reason
and because they're combinations of
secondary structures that are called
super secondary structures sometimes
they're called motifs now there are some
motifs that are super Sekhmet structures
that are worth mentioning so something
only see if the first one I'll talk
about is zinc fingers and these guys are
common in DNA binding proteins
okay so specifically transcription
factors transcription factors of course
are proteins that bind the DNA and are
involved in in helping with
transcription so turning DNA to RNA and
those proteins those transcription
factors often have these little zinc
fingers now a zinc finger has there are
actually multiple kinds of zinc fingers
one I've drawn here it's specifically
called the the c2h2 zinc finger or the
cysts - hiss - zinc finger because we
got these two bit pleated sheet sheet
here sheet here and it kind of goes into
this alpha helix and there are two
cysteines here and here
and 2 histidines here here that are
anchored to this zinc ion okay and this
little loop here that I have drawn ends
up looking something like like this over
to the right so we have a combination of
zinc fingers here and in a protein that
kind of looks like that all these little
circles represent amino acids in a chain
and so on on a larger scale you can
imagine a protein with these little
finger like projections coming out of
them and these are important in binding
DNA okay here's a quick visual of what a
zinc finger might look like on a DNA
strand so of course back here is the
actual DNA strand and here we've got
that that helix and the two beta sheets
that actually make up that zinc finger
and here they are associated with the
DNA double helix okay so it's it's
notable because this this comes up and
shows up pretty often in in DNA binding
proteins okay so yeah as far as super
secondary structures and motifs like I
said this is you can call this a motif
you can call us it protects its
secondary structure unless you come
across someone who says otherwise
but I tend to use them like I said
interchangeably although not everyone
does okay another notable motif leucine
zippers okay or leucine scissors and
they're also common in DNA binding
proteins as well transcription factors
namely so here we have of course some
DNA and there are some so leucine zipper
or leucine scissors basically as a
combination of two alpha helixes that
are kind of orient themselves kind of
like a pair of scissors around DNA and
they're used to bind the DNA and of
course they're they're part of
transcription factors which of course
some can have different functions and in
others but essentially they're all
involved in helping transcription happen
so it looks something
this okay and so notice it kind of looks
like a pair of scissors you know you can
imagine putting your hand around this
portion here the handle kind of snipping
away right if your think about this is a
pair of scissors now they're called
leucine zippers because there are these
little leucine R groups on each of them
here and here and here and here and
there and they're the kind of
hydrophobic interactions between them a
lot of them interact and help be held
together to a certain extent okay
and I don't really know a lot of the
details about these I just know that
leucine zippers in those scenes or
losing scissors tend to show up a lot in
DNA binding proteins so namely I got
like I said transcription factors so
it's just something that worth knowing
and being aware of so here's a better
visual of those leucine zippers or
leucine scissors down there of course is
the DNA and of course these are the
leucine zippers and if we zoom in on
them here we can actually see these loo
scenes right there's a leucine right
here and then the leucine right there
and then another leucine there and I'm
not loosing here so those loose scenes
are actually holding the structure
together okay yeah so that's basically
it as far as motifs and super secondary
structures hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching